personne ne trouve beau maillot secteur
l'échec est patent pool émises à bell
c'est que tu penses que chaque fois que
tu vas dire quelque chose c'est
intéressant même jamais et avec vos
équipes
on a repris toutes les interventions
d'isabelle toutes les interventions
depuis le début de la saison
tout ce qui était pertinent et j'en ai
trouvé d'où les fondamentaux
ça mérite bien un merveilleux deux corps
en métal aime trop bimbo donc c'est bon
et moi parce que je me dis juste parce
qu'elle me fait trop rire tant rigole on
dit à un oiseau un peu non jamais jamais
deux lieutenants
1 c'était et limal qu'un israélien qui
avait fait ça l'est tout est sombre sans
mon cousin était chauffeur de chirac et
donc ils n'aiment prendre 100 grammes
par semaine pour ce raid 100 grammes par
semaine
oui mais c'est la crise avait notamment
déclaré avoir été le fournisseur de
johnny hallyday je suis fan absolu de
johnny c'est ça ça va amener de la
gaieté dans les livres et tous je dis je
me dis quand même le quand même à
retirer sa capuche et plus puisque c'est
c'était des propos de jean esclave et
machin vu que des noirs peut-être que tu
va capter son attention il va laisser
l'autre quand même en paix et il va se
défouler sur toi pendant que l'autre
il a le temps vraiment de souffler que
ça n'aille pas plus loin pas m'ont dit
on dit qu'il travaille chez moi
forcément je comprends qu'ils viennent
aussi bien oui je veux moi je veux que
la lumière soit faite sur cette histoire
le plus rapidement possible vraiment
vraiment jeu que ce soit fait je veux
vraiment que la personne soit interpellé
jean fils avait été victime quoi d'inde
à non mais moi je suis victime d'un mec
qui n'a qui n'a jamais travaillé chez
moi je vous le jure je vous le promets
c'est dramatique ce qui s'est passé non
mais je vous dirais gucci nous on ne
veut pas de cette société là mais
généralement les victimes
cette dame quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé pour le livreur on
veut pas de cet accord aussi était là on
ne veut pas d' escalade de la violence
on aimerait vraiment que tout le monde
puisse se réunir bien comprendre cette
affaire vous avez juste regarder cette
animation pendant par les regards des
clients et leoni ont trois enfants yaël
hassan ali et ilan est en fête
léonie pas revivre en malaisie avec remy
daillet en apportant ses enfants et vous
deviez les rejoindre plus tard c'est ça
l'histoire
le problème c'est qu'en fait on a
cherché des solutions pour scolariser
nos enfants à l'étranger
ma femme est tombée sur le net sur cette
personne on a fait un projet on s'est
rencontré avec sa famille ses sept
enfants qui sont toujours en france pour
partir en malaisie à deux familles pour
s'appuyer mutuellement
ensuite ma femme est partie moi je
devais rester un mois supplémentaire en
france pour finir un peu ma femme est
partie de vente comme on dit ll est au
bout de trois jours alors que tout
allait bien avec ma femme je sais pas
j'ai pas de nouvelles veux plus me
parler sur skype
alors je trouve bon un père de famille
vous savez qu'il ya tout de suite
quelque chose qui se passe ça je demande
le divorce
voilà donc je dis bah écoute maintenant
il faut que tu ramènes les enfants
reviennent alors là hors de question y
aller tu es là bah oui va vite réalisé
que quelque chose ne va pas et moi oui
c'est sûr qu'est ce qui se passe là bas
j'ai tout de suite vu qu'il voulait plus
qu'on communique avec mon père moi
j'avais déjà 14 ans j'avais déjà
l'esprit clair et j'avais tout de suite
vu l'adultère qui venait entre lui et ma
mère je ne dois rien on n'a pas de nom à
pattes avant il est horrible
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de bruit tout le
temps la lumière en permanence on peut
pas faire pire ce n'est pas oubliée je
vais très fort on est enfermé l'eau
[Musique]
le mairie karyn agricole de leclerc de
reprise et une mer à l'est des enfants
comme ça ceux des frères et soeurs ce
message ça la salle à ça me rend dingue
mois mais qu'est ce qui vous rend dans
une merde qui laisse des frères et
soeurs séparés comme ça ne laisse pas
des frais sorti de paris alors à un
moment on l'emprisonnent hall
emprisonnons l'empêchent de sortir en
malaisie et puis comme c'est faux et
qu'il ait émis le souhait de revenir en
france
il est revenu en scène enfin la justice
française est intervenue dans une fois
que la minute que je parle donc
d'obliger son et je suis sonné je ne
trouvais pas être reconnu il laisse moi
parce que le samedi quand je n'étais pas
fier aux secours bien sûr c'est le seul
mot qui vous vient à l'esprit lorsqu'on
dans la paix dans la joie et de l'amour
donc je vais là c'est ce message aux
couleurs gris noir rouge bleu donc voilà
essayer de chercher la paix non à la
violence et puis une non aux racistes du
coup vous avez bien raison de dire ça ce
soit a priori
a priori j'oubliais le patron du
restaurant le bras ce qu a été
auditionné au commissariat de cergy
pontoise il a été convoqué par rapport à
la fermeture administrative de son
restaurant à la suite des menaces de
mort qu'il a reçus il a transmis sa
chaîne de toutes les caméras de
surveillance les policiers ont bien vu
que la personne n'est pas entré dans son
restaurant avec l'enseigne rouge mais
dans un autre restaurant avec une
enseigne noir et apparemment donc cette
personne ne travaillerait pas au bras ce
coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
meilleure façon de se prémunir contre
les démagogues c'est d'étudier le texte
du plus grand démagogue du du xxème
siècle qui a conduit à des catastrophes
et vous êtes une émission je suis venu
vraiment parce que les jeunes regardent
votre nation un et si j'ai un message à
faire passer aux jeunes c'est celui là
retournez vous sur l'histoire du 20e
siècle et regardez à quoi on quand on
conduit les régimes d'extrême droite les
régimes d'extrême droite ont conduit à
auschwitz et les régimes d'extrême
gauche ont conduit au goulag le but par
et insee pour lutter contre l'extrême
droite faudrait faire lire ce livre
ben c'est raté à 100 euros c'est la face
adressé à tous les extrêmes chez nous
même sabot bah je vais y revenir si vous
voulez mais pour lutter contre le
nazisme il faudrait faire lire ce livre
est quand même si vous voulez pour l'ex
sur l'extrême gauche je trouve ça
bizarre de votre parcours métiers
signaux entre les choses mais pour
lutter contre les totalitarismes socafl
contredire ce lien entre les absents
euros c'est une élite qui va se le payer
donc c'est raté et où les idées de jean
luc mélenchon et celle d'homme de
l'extrême droite c'est la même chose et
vous êtes un beau lutter contre les
menaces et que ceux qui sont contre le
racisme et ceux qui sont pour c'est la
même chose
madame madame le pen n'est pas hitler
monsieur mélenchon n'est pas staline
mais il ya une dynamique dans les partis
extrémistes qui amène vous choisirez pas
si de magna un second tour mélenchon le
pen vous choisissez alors que je veux
lui je m'en vais je voudrais je
comprends un fait porte parole et donc
porter une parole compliqué et débile
c'est pas facile pour la saison reste
maurice vous avez vous le faites très
bien ce prime c'est la parole que vous
portez je n'ai pas s'il me porter une
parole comme celle actuelle qui n'a
aucun sens parce que concrètement votre
couvre-feu madame on est tous d'accord
concrètement ça sert à rien un autre
problème on parle de quatrième bague
mais j'ai voulu faire un truc là je fais
une prophétie avocat prophète de temps
en temps c'est pareil si deux provinces
peut-être même avoir une cinquième bague
temps et peut-être même une sixième et
vous savez on s'appelle une épidémie
merde alors quelques pourcentage infime
mais quand même quelques pourcentage de
la population qui vous crois hélas c'est
dangereux parce que je voyais et
attendait de moi
j'ai appelé ma démonstration jean paul
domb faisais moi laissez moi je fais les
rues de seconde on expliqué ils vous
rappellent leur est vraiment jouer sa
parole juste après mais voyez c'est un
peu ça qui nous différencie c'est que
moi j'ai encore une infime partie de la
population qui me croient vous c'est
fini
avant nous annoncer ce qui est possible
ou pas possible je vous demande
d'accueillir le directeur général d'aj
d'eau qui va juste vous annoncer une
bonne nouvelle et qui repartira pour
ceux qui sont là et les autres aussi
d'ailleurs
haha il y aura cette année 0 % de
diminution est la première question qui
me pose c'est vous allez être connus
dans l'appartement et là je réponds bah
comme je vous ai dit en message on sera
endormi rade à l'appartement mais par
contre je compte inviter soit une copine
à elle loue ou sa mère pour juste pour
être témoins et participer à la surprise
est le monsieur refuse l'accès il me dit
je vous laisserai pas rentrer vous avez
maîtres de la musique on vous connaît
vous allez ramener toute l'afrique
c'est incroyable possible d'avoir des
abrutis pareil encore comme ça c'est à
il va vous menacez aussi physiquement
par lui ai dit qu'on va passer - votre
votre adresse jeu arrive en scooter je
vous écraser comme georges floyd
c'était vraiment des menaces des mort
c'était c'était incroyable c'est c'était
choquant c'est les marseillais est ce
que vous allez rester dans les
marseillais aux familles ben ben en fait
c'est une fois la question fatale et
répondu en fait bien sûr ouais ça c'est
dans leurs relations les vite répondu la
même question la vie triple jeu mais en
fait non non clairement on a décidé
d'arrêter sa découverte saison vous
étiez dans sept ans sept ans carla six
ans édition compliqué quand même là bas
on s'est connu là bas on a et on a tout
fait on a une petite fille mais non
parce qu'on s'est cogné la balle je
cours pas mon poste
du coup on fait cela on a décidé de
prendre cette décision
j'ai pas facile quand même parce que
quand ça fait sept ans que tu fais la
même chose c'est dur de prendre cette
décision était bien avec cette
production
franchement c'était ces tests est
vraiment bien avec pour vous arrêter
parce que je pense que pour notre bien
personnelle c'est la chose à faire
après comme j ai vraiment n'était ils
ont été vraiment cool avec nous c'est
l'accent sur la production que ce soit
pas gars quand on adore julien rivage
ici car on les adore aussi allemands il
ya pas de bruit entre vous ça n'a pas
été une décision facile après à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on a vraiment tout donné
dans cette famille des marseillais
maintenant on a aussi envie de penser à
nous